[Musique]
bonjour à tous je m'appelle michael
grande équipe je suis ingénieur de
formation j'ai commencé à travailler il
ya une dizaine d'années et pour tout
vous dire ça a été une véritable douche
froide pour moi quand je suis rentré
dans le monde professionnel
j'espérais qu'après toutes ces années
d'études notamment réussi à lancer à que
j'allais pouvoir contribuer activement à
faire avancer l'humanité est au
contraire tout ce qui m'attendait
c'était finalement de pouvoir maintenir
des systèmes qui était peu efficace
énergivores vieillissant et ça j'avais
vraiment beaucoup de mal à l'accepter
tous les jours je voyais autour de moi
des initiatives libre et ouverte qui
permettait de créer de véritable rupture
technologique avec les modèles connus
j'ai évolué à ce moment là dans des
entreprises certes très porté sur
l'innovation mais qui ne voulait pas
prendre le risque d'une rupture trop
radicale avec leurs modèles des contrats
ronronnant et des habitudes établies
empêcher les véritables révolutions
technologiques de prendre de l'ampleur
aussi des sujets importants à mes yeux
comme le réchauffement climatique et la
raréfaction des énergies non
renouvelables
ça ne trouvais vraiment pas beaucoup
d'écho en 2010 dans le monde de
l'entreprise ça serait peut-être un peu
différent aujourd'hui
j'ai ressenti alors rapidement ce besoin
au fond de moi de m'investir dans
quelque chose qui faisait du sens alors
j'ai décidé avec un groupe d'amis de me
lancer dans une autre réflexion d'un
projet d'après 18 heures c'est à dire un
projet en dehors
nos temps de travail donc nous sommes
laissé le temps de la réflexion pour
choisir un domaine essentiel dans la vie
de tous les jours qu'ils n'avaient pas
encore entamé sa transformation
numérique
on sait donc simplement intéressé à la
pyramide de maslow et ses besoins
fondamentaux en regardant très
précisément ce qu'il se passe du côté de
l'alimentation
et plus précisément la production
alimentaire un secteur ma foi
habituellement assez conservateur ou
désormais le consommateur est très
éloignée de plus en plus animale née du
producteur et l'idée était finalement de
rapprocher les lieux de production des
lieux de consommation avec un objectif
très clair se nourrir sainement et
surtout de manière durable et résiliente
alors pourquoi pourquoi chercher à se
nourrir soit même
pourquoi produire sa propre alimentation
est ce que c'est vraiment une évolution
ce n'est pas finalement un retour en
arrière
il ya tout de même de nombreux obstacles
c'est beaucoup d'échec qu'on a essayé le
temps et aujourd'hui la ressource la
plus précieuse pour chacun d'entre nous
et des alternatives à la production
industriels existent déjà
alors pourquoi chercher à créer un
nouveau modèle est bien être capable de
produire sa propre alimentation permet à
terme de s'émanciper de se libérer du
modèle du salariat et offrir aussi une
véritable résidence dans un monde en
transformation comme aujourd'hui
alors si c'est moi en 2012 dans le
jardin de mon beau père en train de
bricoler un samedi matin et présenté la
première version de ce qui deviendra un
peu plus tard une serre connectés nous
voilà ensuite propulsé huit ans plus
tard nous avons déployé près de 400
serre sur 15 pays et nous étions en
devanture du pavillon français delà du
cms 2020 le dernier à las vegas en
présentiel
il devrait révéler maintenant comment
nous avons réussi à impulser cette
transformation profonde qui a
aujourd'hui un impact majeur sur la vie
de milliers de personnes dans
l'innovation
il existe un chemin le chemin classique
académique qui cherche à faire sauter un
verrou technique l'identifier
le faire sauter trouver des moyens pour
y arriver protégez ensuite la
connaissance exploiter les résultats sur
des années alors ce chemin généralement
longs coûteux c'est à dire avec une
vraie barrière financière à l'entrée pas
facile à contourner
et ça ne permet pas de tester rapidement
la réponse d'un marché il existe ensuite
un autre chemin le nouveau chemin c'est
d'inspirer un changement proposé une
vision incarner des valeurs comme la
transparence et la solidarité pour faire
ensuite grandir une communauté et c'est
ce chemin là que nous avons emprunté
notre vision nos valeurs depuis le début
n'ont quasiment pas changé elle se sont
à peine affiné j'ai compris avec le
temps que les personnes qui nous ont
rejoints ont fait leur choix non pas
pour le produit tel qu'il est ou tel
qu'il était mais pour ce qu'il deviendra
grâce à eux et leur contribution
leur retour est surtout pour cette
vision que nous incarnons et que nous
portons au quotidien durant ces
dernières années
j'ai aussi eu la chance de côtoyer de
nombreux porteurs et porteuses de
projets à fort impact environnemental et
social certains ont réussi à trouver un
modèle économique et ont réussi à
croître mais de nombreux aussi ont
abandonné et pour des raisons qui sont
quasi systématiquement les mêmes tout
d'abord le découragement face à la
difficulté c'est très dur au début
surtout quand on fait un pas de côté
indispensable le manque de focus la
recherche de pureté et d'absolu il faut
bien démarrer par quelque chose est
généralement la solution première n'est
jamais idéal
on va voir pourquoi on peut aussi
aujourd'hui difficilement mettre tout le
monde d'accord vous avez vis-à-vis de
toutes les sensibilités qui existent
quand on démarre une aventure
entrepreneuriale
le plus important c'est de démarrer mais
c'est aussi d'avancer je me suis rendu
compte aussi qui ne suffit pas d'aligner
toutes les bonnes idées trouvées sur
internet pour créer sa start up ça
serait bien trop simple ma conviction
on ne pourra pas créer le monde de
demain avec les outils d'hier le rejet
de tout ce que ce qui a été produit par
la civilisation pour moi c'est
clairement une impasse c'est une
conviction personnelle que je porte les
ingénieurs sont les artisans du
compromis
ils ont plein de défauts mais souvent
ils ont un point de vue assez mesuré sur
les choses ils savent évaluer à peu près
correctement le rat
bénéfice risque et ça c'est très
important etienne klein disait il ya
quelques mois que les ingénieurs peuvent
inventer un imaginaire qui soit assez
réaliste assez crédible et je trouve que
c'est assez juste pour le coup en résumé
pour bien commencer
on a besoin d'une utopie qui inspire
d'une réalité qui rassure et finalement
d'un quotidien qui se transforme étape
par étape
alors quelles sont ces étapes pour créer
un avenir souhaitable et durable cela
implique des transformations les
transformations qui ont un coût
financier et environnemental
ces transformations apporte aussi de la
valeur ajoutée qui permet d'amortir ses
impacts par rapport à une situation de
référence
alors je vous donner l'exemple des
panneaux solaires l'installation de
panneaux solaires sur un toit est un
investissement financier d'abord par
leur fabrication leur installation ils
sont aussi un coût environnemental et
tout ça s'amortit dans le temps si on
compare ça à une consommation habituelle
surtout dans un pays où la production
électrique et très carbonée alors ce
raisonnement s'applique de la même
manière à un récupérateur d'eau de pluie
à un adoucisseur osmoseur à une pompe à
chaleur à une voiture électrique et
naturellement aussi à une serre
connectés tels qu'on l'a inventé
aujourd'hui l'objet de l'évolution de
cette technologie
c'est de s'améliorer d'améliorer leurs
performances de réduire ce temps de
retour sur investissement est de
minimiser naturellement la dette
environnementale et ça c'est un vrai
challenge car une fois amorti il reste
un coût de fonctionnement et de
maintenance résiduelles pour un bénéfice
mesurable et ça c'est tout à fait normal
dans sa consommation au quotidien
alors ce fonctionnement c'est que je
décris c'est celui d'une machine mais
c'est aussi celui d'un système vivant
d'une cellule d'un organisme complexe
c'est aussi celui d'un écosystème donc
au premier jour rien n'est parfait c'est
c'est normal les panneaux solaires n'ont
pas toujours été aussi performants et
accessibles
les batteries au lithium sont
intéressantes mais elles sont encore
assez cher et le bilan carbone de
l'acier de l'aluminium de la production
d'hydrogène n'est pas encore tout à fait
anodin et pourtant les choses avancent
des personnes brillantes travaille
là-dessus itération après l'itération
les produits safin évolue avec le volume
on a aussi capable de trouver les bon
levier pour faire suivis industrielle
par exemple comment nous avons dépassé
les 200 s'est reconnecté nous avons pu
pousser notre fournisseurs a repensé
reconcevoir lasserre pour simplifier sa
logistique et son stockage
nous avons ainsi limiter l'impact
carbone de sa livraison est surtout
aujourd'hui nous sommes désormais
capables délivré plus de serre dans des
endroits auparavant complètement
inaccessibles comme sur les toits les
terrasses en ville et tout ça avec un
petit camion alors toutes ces
transformations ça ne s'est pas fait
tout seul
il ya eu des effets de bord n'ont prévu
des régressions parfois des patchs
indispensable des moments difficiles
bref rien de surprenant quand on
transforme quelque chose ça pas
systématiquement par là c'est ainsi que
depuis le premier jour nous avons
continué à avancer à l'ecoute de notre
communauté et avec la notoriété des
talents nous aurons ensuite rejoint
rejoint notre équipe pour continuer à
structurer la société est le meilleur
pour nous reste à venir
nous avons naturellement continué à
publier l'intégralité de nos plans et de
nos programmes informatiques sous un
format libre c'est cet esprit de partage
et d échange et de nombreuses personnes
se sont déjà emparés pour les
transformer pour les faire évoluer
et c'est vraiment surprenant de voir
finalement que nos propres travaux nous
échappe
il évolue par eux mêmes alors s'il ya
parmi vous quelques entrepreneurs et
entrepreneurs en puissance
je conclurai par quelques conseils
personnels fait preuve d'une
détermination sans faille
n'abandonnez jamais car vous trouverez
toujours quelqu'un qui pense avoir une
meilleure idée que vous c'est comme ça
et au final ce qui perdure c'est la mise
en oeuvre c'est ce qui reste c'est pas
seulement les paroles
avant de vous lancer assurez vous que la
science et la physique sont à peu près
de votre côté donc rajouté un os 4 0 une
équation c'est pas tout à fait la même
chose
pensez-y avant de vous lancer comme ça
dans une bataille peut-être perdu d
avance
préparez vous un long chemin car
l'entrepreneuriat va vous embarquez pour
des années donc c'est une aventure d'une
vie ça se passe non pas en six mois mais
en plusieurs années et pour conclure je
dirais que considérer que le pire est
pour certains pour moi c'est capituler
alors qu'au contraire innover et
transformé l'humanité c'est résister au
défaitisme oser c'est prendre le risque
d'échouer et en empruntant ce nouveau
chemin
c'est aussi l'opportunité de réussir
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]